Larry Diamond, thank you so much for joining me on 20 Minute Leaders.
Really great to have you.
Thank you Michael, it's great to be with you.
Wonderful. Okay.
Larry, a Senior Fellow at Hoover Institute.
Senior Fellow at the Freeman Spogli Institute at Stanford University
Beautiful background behind you.
We've known each other for quite some time now.
Most prominently, through the incredible class, the Spirit of Democracy
that you taught me in the beginning of the year
which gave me a ten-week deep dive into what is democracy,
what is the amazing work that you've been doing there with your colleagues,
and I can't wait for this 20 minutes to talk about democracy
and where we're headed as a world.
So, maybe just give me a little bit of brief down of who are you
and why are you even interested in democracy?
Well, I'm a Senior Fellow at the institution over my shoulder, the Hoover Institution,
on World Revolution and Peace and at the Freeman Spogli Institute.
I'm a Professor by courtesy of Political Science in Sociology at Stanford,
and I co-edit the journal of democracy
and obviously I care about democracy.
I believe in freedom and individual dignity.
And I have always believed from a philosophical standpoint
but now I know, after 40 years of study from a scholarly standpoint
that Liberal Democracy is the best way, and I believe the only way
to fully ensure a human dignity.
Okay. So, you're saying I heard freedom, I heard human dignity, and then liberal democracy.
Why is there the word "liberal" in front of the word democracy?
Well, you had earlier hoped that I would define democracy, so let me do it in this way.
A democracy is a system of government in which people can choose their leaders
and replace their leaders in free and fair elections.
If you don't have that, you can't get real political accountability.
Maybe you can pressure semi-authoritarian regime
but without the ability to remove leaders who mis perform
and put a competing policy options to the citizenry in regular free and fair elections
you can't ensure political accountability and you are very likely to slide rapidly down the path
of tyranny and abusive power and abuse of human rights.
At the same time, the political dimension of competition and accountability
through the, let's be honest, fairly crude and limited instrument,
indispensable though it is, of regular free and fair elections is not enough.
And the liberal dimension is everything else.
It's ensuring that you have very extensive rights of speech, press, association.
That you have a strong rule of law in which the courts are fully independent.
That you have a strong constitutional order that will defend human dignity
and provide at least means to correct the kinds of abuses of human rights
that we're now seeing in too many American cities,
targeted against African-Americans in particular.
And that, you know you can at least pursue the goal, difficult though it is to achieve
of social, economic, and political equality.
And some reasonable degree of justice.
Right. So, a big part of it is the peoples' wish, right?
The peoples vote and the human dignity.
And a huge part of that is information. It’s the dissemination of information.
If we look 20, 30 years ago, there was one or two channels
in which the information was disseminated.
Pretty accountable in a lot of areas in the world.
Is that information accurate or not?
Now, every kid with a Tiktok account, or an Instagram or a Facebook,
Those are news channels.
They're no longer social media channels.
To me, they're news channels because I consider myself an educated being.
I'm all about democracy and I'm all about information.
I get so much of my news from my social media feeds even without knowing it.
Just because it's there.
So, what are some of the biggest challenges that you've seen over the past 40 years
going forward with how do we deal with this information around the world.
You know, especially considering the 2016 elections,
the upcoming election, and so on.
Well, there's the eternal challenge of ensuring freedom of information.
And the plurality of information.
It's not just the people who have access to information.
There needs to be the freedom to gather report,
convey, distill, and opinionate in terms of information.
And I say it's an eternal challenge because once again we're seeing a war
on independent media, often a deadly one,
by Autocrats around the world who don't want to be held accountable,
don't want to have their corruption, abuse of power exposed.
I believe there was just a prime minister who almost tried to get a journalist into jail.
In a specific country that I'm related with.
Well, you know Israel is not even close to being the worst offender
even among so-called democracies, not to mention all the other countries of the Middle East.
But we're seeing pressure on the independent media
even in the countries that have been considered liberal democracies.
And I'm sorry to say that now we have a President of the United States
who has contempt for independent media.
Has called them "purveyors of fake news and enemies of the people"
And this gives ... comfort and encouragement to autocrats around the world
who want to subdue and completely control independent media.
What is your reaction to this
and political scientist like yourself who are watching
as you know, the leader of the free world
is perhaps moving, steering very rapidly away from
the so-called liberal democracy which we're aiming for.
Well, I have been ever since his illiberal and populist election campaign in 2015 and 2016.
And in particular, since he assumed the presidency and began to bring
these themes of disinformation, intolerance, contempt for opposition,
contempt for independent institutions and independent media in to the Whitehouse
I have been increasingly disturbed, angered, and horrified by what he's been doing.
I think increasingly it represents a danger,
not only to our democratic values but to our institutions
which you see in the way he's been running rough shot over separation of powers.
Misusing the military. Misusing the justice department.
Dividing the country. Firing inspectors, general, and anyone who would try to hold him
and his administration to account.
So, I think civil society here and elsewhere needs to stand up to this.
And people from across the political spectrum need to rally behind common principles,
bedrock minimum principles of not just democracy but liberal democracy
which include tolerance, pluralism, respect for the independence of the media civil society
and accountability institutions, and a rule of law.
But Michael, I did not want to neglect the other half of your question
which revolves around the new era we are in social media
and that challenge is fresh because before we thought it was enough to just have independent media.
They would constitute an arena of pluralism of information
and contestation of ideas.
Maybe there would be some irresponsibility and sensationalism in the midst of it,
but people would kind of ferret it out.
In the era of social media, with the extraordinary precision and power of targeting
micro targeting - it's unbelievable -  and the algorithms that the social media platforms generate to do this
and the anonymity of many of the purveyors of this information
or what we saw in the 2016 election campaign, the deliberate disguising
of the sources of this disinformation.
We're really in a new and much more dangerous era.
So, okay. I mean, it's sad to think that. But I'm now thinking ahead.
Ok, so, I'm in the realm of the millennial generation or generation Z and Y,
What is our responsibility here?
Because honestly, I think that most of the people that I'm around.
We can all vouch for democracy. We don't really know what democracy is.
I'm very fortunate to have been in your class and to have listened to you passionately
explain to us also the amazing work that I would love to get to the American in One Room.
Work that you've done. But what is our responsibility now
as educated young adult who are entering the work force
and except for the active voting, the once every four years.
What do we need to do in order to ensure that we're moving in the right direction?
Because it sounds like this is now a nationwide reunite.
It's no longer does the politicians that have to work it out amongst themselves.
Let me first come to the information and then I'll come to the action.
We all need to be better educated and better informed.
And to be well informed, to be intelligently informed,
and I'd say to be responsibly informed in a democracy,
we can't be passively informed. And by passively, I mean,
allow the main or principal, or only sources of our information to be what is conveyed to us
increasingly, I repeat, through micro-targeting in algorithmic formulas
that constrain what we're getting.
And give us what they think is going to entertain or outraged us
but fixate our attention on their website.
And so we need to be proactive to seek out multiple sources of informationa
and to you know check and verify the information we're getting
which means getting on others' engaging and creative
and intensive information searches to check out assertions
and try to asses and validate the authenticity and credibility
of some of the claims that are being made before we retweet them, repeat them,
or post them on our various social media sites.
Is that feasible to ask of a 20-year old to check their sources? Yes, it is.
I think we can ask it of a 15-year old.
And if you doubt me, please interview my colleague in the school of education Sam Weintraub
who has been working to develop protocols and educational tools for - Sam Wineburg
excuse me - develop educational tools for young people to learn
how to confirm, or asses, or validate the claims they're seeing on the internet
and not just swallow them wholesale and therefor become at least unwitting
purveyors of misinformation.
But in addition on the action side, Michael,
don't dismiss the importance of that voting once every four years.
It's the last line of defense for political accountability, good governance,
and you know, the protection of civil liberties.
But in addition, we've seen in the last two weeks, since the murder of George Floyd
in Minneapolis, that civil society action, peaceful non-violent discipline
coordinated in passioned civil society action can make a difference
and can bring about social change.
We saw it in the civil rights movement in the United States.
We saw it with the women’s suffragist movement in the United States.
We saw it with the anti-war movement in the United States.
And I think we are entering a period of profound, creative,
renewing social and political reform in the United States.
That gives me a lot of optimism. And Larry, one of the main themes
that we were discussing in our sessions was this idea of polarization
and how do we bring people together of polarized opinions into the same room
and to be able to have educated discussions and to really listen
and not just to be present.
And you ran a fascinating experiment you can call it,
or, I think it's much greater than just and experiment.
The word experiment doesn't give justice to the amazing work
that you and Professor Fishkin did.
America in One Room. Bringing together people from all different sides.
Talk to me about that. What was that about?
Well, I was privileged to be part of a very imaginative and far-reaching exercise
in Dallas, Texas last year led by my colleague James Fishkin,
Department of Communication at Stanford,
to bring 526 randomly selected Americans of all ethnicities, and parties,
and ideological persuasions, and diverse places in the United States together
for much of four days to deliberate on some of the major issues facing the United States
in terms of healthcare, the economy, immigration, environment, and foreign policy.
And this was another iteration of the model, the deliberative polling
that James Fishkin has developed and applied over a hundred times
in more than a dozen countries.
And what we found is what a gem and his deputy director Alice Siu,
of the Center for Deliberative for Democracy
and others have found when they've done these things
that when you bring people together, under good conditions
where they have access to well researched and balanced issue briefing papers
and where they can hear different points of view,
in plenary sessions on the issues, and where they can interact and talk about the issues
respectfully in small groups with people that come from different places
and may have different opinions, their opinions changed.
And we found generally, on a lot of issues, not all but on a striking number of issues,
that people, that polarization reduced on the issues.
Pretty dramatic.
It there was change the change was toward less polarization.
With republicans and democrats, progressives and conservatives coming together
either by moving more toward one position than the other
or moving towards some you know, kind of creative common ground.
And not least Michael, in importance, when people got to know one another
we had people who said, "You know, I've never--"
an African-American woman who said, "I’ve never interacted like this with a white person before."
And vice-versa. Or white person from a rural area.
They see them as human beings.
An affect of polarization is emotional tribalism attenuates
and that's very important for the future of our democracy.
I think one of the most important questions from the survey afterwards
that I really resonated with was, it wasn't exactly that but it was around
How do you think the other side is willing to listen to you?
It was of that nature. That was a dramatic shift.
All of a sudden you see republicans who are shifting and saying,
"Yeah. democrats are listening to us" Democrats are saying the same things about republicans.
And to me that was much more powerful than any shift on any topic.
It was about of this essence of are we willing to collaborate with the other side,
to acknowledge the differences
but acknowledge that at the end we're all citizens of this wonderful country,
of this wonderful world and we have a shared responsibility to reach a resolution
and to better the lives of all the citizens.
I can't believe 20 minutes is almost up.
I have to leave with the last question. It always sucks that it ends so quickly
and I only get a third of what I want to talk about.
But Larry, I would love to hear three words that you would describe yourself as
or if I would ask any of your students, how would they describe Larry Diamond as?
Well, you'll have to ask them,
but I would describe myself, first as a Democrat with a small D.
I believe deeply that liberal democracy is the best form of government
and a pre-condition for achieving social justice to human dignity.
I'm very proud of the coincidence that my parents left me unwittingly
that my initials Larry Diamond are the same initials as Liberal Democracy.
But secondly, I am a Reformer. I am an Activist.
I'm not a revolutionary but I do believe we need to struggle for change.
And third, I think of myself as a scholar but most of all as a teacher
trying to convey these ideas both to my students
and a wider community of students around the world.
So, thank you for giving me an opportunity to do it here.
Larry, I wanna use this opportunity to thank you again for the incredible inspiration
that you've provided me personally and everybody else in my classes
and I'm sure that you teach in Stanford.
I'll never forget the very first session. It was Monday morning,
the first quarter of my freshman year, and I walk into the Spirit of Democracy class
and you're standing in front of us talking about what the class will be about
and within about five or six minutes, you go down the path of the America in One Room
and we see the passion in your eyes and I believe that you even started tearing up a little bit
and we looked at each other afterwards, and we said,
"Wow. So, this is where we came to."
And so, I wanna thank you for that inspiration.
And I'll take that with me wherever I go.
And I look forward to maintaining this relationship over many many years.
Me too. Thank you, Michael.
Take care. Bye bye.